you guys do this bit on on your show
totally jk which i love and have done
for many years we should explain
we the reason we're here is to promote
our bi-monthly monday night show at the
ucb theater
actually while this is airing if you
want to catch last 20 minutes of our
show
at ucb you should go go now
yeah we're across from the scientology
celebrity center oh wait speaking of
which actually we
can you do the show tonight we have a
show oh yeah nina walsh canceled you
wanna do our show today tonight tonight
yeah uh maybe
great okay great that is very diplomatic
yeah you're not gonna i don't know why i
could have just lied
here's the truth
this show is tiring as [__] yeah
i go to bed around 9 30 10.
like angela lansbury
i read three or four pages of chicken
soup for the soul you solve one murder
and i do one of these
and then that's adorable and then next
thing i know i'm back on the set do you
drink your nightmare tea
i had joe come over and i gave him as
his standard shaman dream tea yeah he
bought tea from a shaman on the internet
and he was like it's supposed to induce
a lucid dream state yeah
and it did for me
so we drank i drank a hole we drank it
tastes terrible shaman get on and put
some cinnamon
it was nasty certainly there are healing
properties to separate
in whatever and so
we both drank the tea i went home
did not have a
any dream let alone a lucid dream yes i
had to wake up to let a cable guy into
my apartment he left i went back to
sleep see that's key and then had the
most vivid nightmare i've ever had in my
life
see some people invite their friends
over for one more drink i'm like would
you like to come over and go to the
other side
i had a lucid nightmare i was getting
chased through a building yelling wake
up
wake up
this is pete's tea
it was terrible next time very commonly
slamming your back against something
will wake you up so anyway
calmly
commonly slamming your back yeah okay
try it
didn't work just making sure this wasn't
a nightmare